Grey's Anatomy star Kevin McKidd and his  wife Jane Parker have called it quits  picked up on them after 17 years  together a rep for the former couple  told people on Saturday quote Kevin and  Jane have jointly decided to end their  marriage the kid and his wife Wed in  1999 and share two children a 16 year  old son Joseph and 14 year old daughter  Iona  their rep also added they look forward  to continuing to co-parent their  children who have been their top  priority and will continue to enjoy a  close and caring relationship the 42  year old Scottish actor has played dr.  Owen Hunt  on the ABC show Grey's Anatomy since  2008 and is reportedly gearing up for  season 13  you